Corea del Norte ha lanzado hoy un misil
balístico intercontinental o icbm que
aterrizado a solo 200 km al oeste de las
costas del norte de Japón y que subraya
la insistencia al régimen de pyongyang
en seguir mejorando sus arsenales y
empeora la situación de tensión que se
vive Ya de por sí en la región según los
ejércitos surcoreanos y japonés el misil
recorrió unos mil kilómetros en unos 69
minutos alcanzando una altura máxima de
unos 6.000 kilómetros y una velocidad
equivalente a unas 22 veces la del
sonido este último proyectil norcoreano
se une a otro de corto alcance lanzado
en la víspera y sobre todo a una
treintena de misiles de diverso tipo una
cifra récord lanzados por el régimen de
Kim Jong una principios de noviembre
para dar respuesta a unas grandes
maniobras aéreas de seúl y Washington
precisamente los ejércitos de Corea del
Sur y Estados Unidos han respondido hoy
a este icbm lanzando bombas guiadas
sobre plataformas de lanzamiento de
misiles norcoreanas simuladas y
ensayando también informaciones de
combate con diversos cazas lo que Envía
un serio mensaje de advertencia apium
yang las insistentes pruebas de armas
norcoreanas unidas a las maniobras de
los dos aliados están llevando los
niveles de tensión en la Península
coreana a máximos históricos y ya no
solo por la creciente sofisticación del
Arsenal norcoreano sino por la
posibilidad de que se produzcan como
apuntan los expertos errores de cálculo
que puedan deparar un conflicto armado
peligrosísimo